there is little let up in the nation's
battle against the coronavirus more than
58 000 new cases in the u.s reported
friday
pushing the total number of infections
close to 5
million the nationwide death toll is
more than 161 thousand
the concerns of reopening the university
of north carolina have caught the
attention of police in chapel hill
violations of local or state
restrictions could be punishable by a
fine or a jail sentence
after a large group of women at a
sorority event was seen not wearing
masks or social
distancing schools are wrestling with
how they can keep students and staff
safe should they decide to reopening
everybody's still making those decisions
in many cases
michael george is in new york city this
morning where classrooms will be open
this fall michael good morning
jeff good morning this fall children
will be able to walk through the doors
of marine park junior high once again
and new york's governor says the only
reason they're able to make that happen
is because the state's infection rate
has fallen to one percent
but in parts of the country where the
virus is raging out of control
parents and teachers have a difficult
decision to make
at a time when the nation's children are
heading back to some sort of school
a new report shows more than 338
thousand children tested positive
as of the end of july 97 000 of those
cases reported in the last two weeks of
the month
a 40 percent jump and more than 25
children died in july alone
dr tina hardart hopes increased testing
of children
will help determine what role they play
in transmission
the kits are shipped to the families
they're taught how to collect these
samples and then the samples are
sent back by the families to a central
repository but the pressure to get kids
into classrooms
has left superintendents in more than 13
thousand different school districts
across the country
trying to figure out how to keep
children safe amidst a myriad of public
health mandates and advisories
and also handle learning differences in
niles michigan superintendent dan
applegate is depending on plexiglas to
use for students with learning
difficulties
as i'm sitting here and i could
articulate the student on the other side
would be wearing a mask
and then i could put my mask on that
student could drop their mask and
articulate as well
in new york city the nation's largest
school district
it was announced schools will open their
doors
the chancellor and his team have worked
incessantly
to get this right they've looked at
examples from all over the world
of what will keep the school community
safe and they've made a series of
choices of how to do things from a
health and safety lens first
while also making sure we can educate
our kids mayor bill de blasio gave
parents until last night to register
students to either come to school
learn from home or do a combination of
both
you're going to see a very clean and and
disinfected bus
lawrence township indiana is cleaning
its buses with
hospital grade disinfectant spray we've
actually got fogging machines
but here many students aren't expected
to get on the bus
35 percent of them are predicted to stay
home to learn remotely
while many school districts have
announced they won't open at all
so what does a reopen school look like
well here in new york the specifics
haven't even been worked out yet but we
do know
that it means students and teachers
wearing masks increased coveted
screenings
and schools could shut down once again
if the infection rate rises jeff
all right michael george thank you very
much